I'm here with dr. David agus who's a
professor of medicine and engineering at
University of Southern California and
what are we looking at right over here
so you could see on the right top there
is a captain or the British Royal Navy
named James Lind and he was a remarkable
guy actually did one of the first
clinical trials and I'll tell you about
in a minute but in the Battle of
Trafalgar between the British and the
French he did something very clever and
then on his ships
he had fresh fruit he had limes hence
the term limeys for the British soldiers
what was amazing is is that being out at
sea for several weeks at a time the
soldiers were all start to develop
scurvy which is a lack of vitamin C what
happens to someone will they have scurvy
so that can vitamin C is involved in
collagen synthesis which is kind of the
scaffolding of the body so your body
starts to degrade you start to get
bleeding gums your tissues start to fall
apart and it yields up in death and most
people if no vitamin C is given I see
all your connective tissue in your body
starts to degrade literally starts to
grain build itself so in the late 90s I
was working in a laboratory and I read
his book it's called a treatise on
scurvy from 1746 Wow and in it he said
that talked all about doing autopsies
and people with scurvy people my age and
I'm in my 40s have never seen scurvy
ever right so the first time I ever
heard about scurvy what it look like was
reading it and what he mentioned was
that the brain was always intact and
people with scurvy so when I look to
identify how vitamin C worked in the
body what the transporter was the first
place I look was the brain and science
it kind of overlooked looking there for
this transporter because nobody read the
book in a long time when we cloned which
has identified the gene to allow vitamin
C to go in and out of cells and it's a
pretty cool molecule because the vitamin
C that you eat is called ascorbic acid
right and in order to get into cells it
has to be converted to another molecule
called dehydroascorbic else' but what's
amazing is is that in that medical
textbooks as late as the 1920s and 30s
they still scald scurvy and infectious
zees because at the end of his book he
put a paragraph we said I happened to
sell the extract of lime to prevent
scurvy and it didn't work I see and it
didn't work because as soon as you
squeeze that lime at room temperature
right right the vitamin C degrades and
so people tried to reproduce what he did
and they couldn't and you know he was an
entrepreneur he couldn't sell limes
because everybody had limes he tried to
sell the extract of limes and it didn't
work so even though he was able to in
the clinical trial that he ran was
regarding limes and yes sir took these
nuns and he gave them using a diet that
had no fruits in it and then a diet with
limes and he showed that the people that
the lines didn't develop scurvy and the
others died so he just watched some nuns
have get scurvy and died not the most
ethical expect oh okay so he's not
necessarily the most he did that in the
1740s and that wacko person in the world
but but but he learned that oh the limes
will at least it seemed prevent scurvy
right remember what a vitamin is and
this is key yeah what a vitamin is is
something the body can't synthesize
enough of so for example a mouse has an
enzyme that allows it to synthesize
vitamin C so in a mouse it wouldn't be
called vitamin C it would just be called
ascorbic acid because it's not really a
vice interesting interesting so if we
were Mouse doctors where we would just
we just called good cause korvac acid
exactly nothing mean if we were mice we
call it ascorbic acid - exactly um or
they probably have their own language
right right yeah but uh but in all of us
we have certain things that we have to
get from the outside from food right
those are called vitamins and minerals
right so a vitamin doesn't mean that
more is better it doesn't mean that is
good for you it just remains that you
require a small amount of it and your
body can't synthesize it so this guy
right here he does the clinical trials
with the nuns he figures out that Lyme
people who have fruit and who have lyme
they're not getting they're not getting
scurvy and so he sends out a bunch of
Lyme with the British the Navy during
the Napoleonic Wars and and that's why
they're called limeys and that's and and
and
I guess apparently they won the war
because of that because once you're at
war you're several weeks to sea at sea
the French Navy's getting decimated
because with scurvy right because
they're not getting their eating dried
beef jerky or whatever else they might
be they're not getting fruit and it's
really so because of that discovery
because of that discovery that the
British won the Battle of Trafalgar
exactly and I mean there are two lessons
from it one is you know you can't just
say generically lime no matter how the
fruit is how its cared for you know once
he juiced it and put it at room
temperature it was all gone
right so besides the fact that this guy
get a clinical trial that that was no
you know killed a bunch of nuns
he also said hey this is a business
opportunity right I've just shown you
maybe he felt that he didn't get you
know compensated properly for saving the
British fleet from Napoleon and says I'm
gonna make a business out of this and so
he decides to start taking lime juice
extract and tries to sell it as a cure
for what happened why didn't he become
rich because didn't work once you
squeeze it out of line it degrades the
vitamin C literally it's called oxidizes
and it happens when is it exposed to
light and oxygen at room temperature
almost instantaneously I see so what
happened was is that when the when the
the soldiers were eating the lime in
their whole form sure you might chew on
a little bit you might cut it a little
bit but there's whole pieces of line
that were not exposed where the vitamin
C wasn't exposed to the air or whatever
else that actually got into someone's
there's a reason Tropicana when they
sell you oranges it's in a cardboard
container that gets no light in and it's
refrigerated right because that keeps
the vitamin C intact right but because
people didn't realize that because I
said hey okay for whatever reason they
didn't get scurvy during Trafalgar but
hey we have the lime extract and that's
not preventing scurvy people kind of
gave up on that whole hypothesis that it
was about the vitamin C that's what
you're saying right as recent as the
1920s people thought it was about it was
an it some type of an infectious disease
exactly so the key is when you start to
look at data you have to look at all
aspects of it and somebody smart sort of
looked and said listen how he did his
first experiment was different than what
he was selling and trying to validate
that's interesting if someone had looked
at that for 200 years we would have
saved a lot of lives right because
remember it was from 1946 until the
1930s when we discover what vitamin C
truly was
and so a lot of lives were lost them
because nobody paid attention
fascinating and then there's these other
other side effects of one you don't know
a vitamin doesn't necessarily mean a
good thing that's something that's kind
of programmed into us maybe by the
nutraceutical industry yeah but but and
even if it is a good thing it's not
necessarily even a good thing to get it
in a processed form and this isn't some
type of like you know tree-hugging
organic this is there's some science
here is that look if it's something as
an antioxidant and it gets exposed to
oxygen or some other or oxidizing agent
it's not gonna be able to do any good
anymore it's kamek and so that's where
the whole actual fruit is is going to be
more remember one orange has a couple of
milligrams of vitamin C one two three
milligrams one pill has 500 milligrams
right so whoever makin those pills kind
of forgot what was going on in nature
right right fascinating this is very
good